[Music]
foreign
[Music]
she'll be just fine let's talk to go by
his words and deeds Avengers Infinity
Wars Thanos may be the most consummate
and Powerful foe the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is Unleashed and what makes for
greatness when it comes to villainy is
it a grand plan executed with a blob an
iconic look or an immediately quotable
motto or is it a knack for banter with
the hero
how will your friends have time for me
when they're so busy fighting you
this usually works well performance
issues at the end of the day thanos's
merits is one of the great villains will
be debated but for now let's take a look
at some of the big screens greatest
superhero foes as we count down the best
superhero movie villains
[Music]
starting with number 10 Captain America
the Winter Soldier yes yes he isn't a
villain by choice as he's very much a
weapon of Hydra in the film but Bucky
Barnes is very effective at playing the
part his Soviet brainwashing is so
effective that when activated almost no
emotional appeal will work on him well
at least until his old friend Steve
Rogers AKA Captain America finally
breaks through and really Bucky's
relationship with Steve is part of what
makes him so compelling starring
Sebastian Stan Chris Evans Scarlett
Johansson and directed by Anthony and
Joe Russo critics say suspenseful and
politically astute Captain America the
Winter Soldier is a superior entry in
the MCU and is sure to Thrill Marvel
diehards Get Me Off the Grid calculating
route to secure location
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
number nine Spider-Man homecoming
despite a strong work ethic and good
management skills Adrian tombs turned to
Crime when Tony Stark and government
officials bulldozed over his contract to
clean up Manhattan following the Battle
of New York now granted the swiftness
with which he became a black market
weapons manufacturer suggests all he
ever needed was a gentle shove to
embrace villainy but the opening scene
of Spider-Man homecoming made him
immediately understandable and
compelling as a villain and even
sympathetic once his relationship to
Spider-Man's world is revealed starring
Michael Keaton Tom Holland Marissa Tomei
and directed by John Watts critics say
Spider-Man homecoming does whatever
second reboot can delivering a colorful
fun adventure that fits snugly in the
sprawling MCU without getting bogged
down in franchise building
hey Pedro
foreign
[Music]
bingo
[Music]
number eight Superman the movie
excusing some of the camp value to
Hackman's Luther particularly in the
sequel he exudes the key quality of
Superman's arch foe egotism Luther a
real estate swindler in these films only
decides to fight Superman because his
ego dictates it consequently Superman
cannot really appeal to his emotions
none are present as he plans to remake
the West Coast In His Image starring
Gene Hackman Christopher Reeve Margot
Kidder and directed by Richard Donner
critics say Superman definitely Blends
humor in gravitas taking advantage of
the perfectly cast Christopher Reeve to
craft a loving nostalgic tribute to an
American pop culture icon
foreign
[Music]
little souvenir from the old Hometown
I've spared no expense to make you feel
right at home
[Music]
you were great in your day Superman
but it just stands to reason
when it came time to cash in your chips
it's hot water
diseased Maniac would be your Banker
Mind Over muscle
[Music]
you know even care where the other
missiles headed do you
certainly I do
I know exactly what is headed Hackensack
New Jersey
[Music]
number seven Captain America Civil War
currently the avengers's greatest foe is
not a flamboyant God or a maniacal robot
but a sad quiet man with a detailed plan
and working knowledge of governmental
procedures Zemo destabilizes the world
for a very personal and ultimately small
goal hurt the Avengers the way they hurt
him he also succeeds leaving Captain
America a fugitive and Tony Stark so
isolated that he has to Pal around with
a spider-themed teenage hero starring
Daniel brol Chris Evans Robert Downey Jr
and directed by Anthony and Joe Russo
critics say Captain America Civil War
begins the next wave of Marvel movies
with an action-packed superhero
Blockbuster boasting a decidedly
non-cartoonish plot and the courage to
explore thought-provoking themes
Jelani
[Music]
javoy
stop
s yet stop
[Music]
the edge
things
[Music]
number six Spider-Man 2.
one of the most sympathetic villains on
the list Molina's Doc Ock was as much a
victim of his passions as he was a
willing accomplice and a plan to destroy
Spider-Man the cruelty that emerges in
him came from his cybernetic implants a
crucial detail that becomes clear when
he finally reasserts control and
realizes he was trying to kill his
friend Peter Parker also the warmth with
which he welcomes Peter a guy in
desperate need of a positive male role
model makes his turn all the more tragic
starring Alfred Molina Tobey Maguire
Kirsten dunce and directed by Sam Rainey
critics say boasting an entertaining
villain and deeper emotional Focus
Spider-Man 2 is a Nimble sequel that
improves upon the original
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number five Superman 2.
thanks to stamp Zod is as much a staple
in Superman's Rogues Gallery as Lex
Luthor seemingly reversed Zod can lash
out without hesitation despite the air
of refinement stamp gives the character
he is just another Petty dictator a
point underscored when he takes control
of the White House and by implication
the world only to suffer from
conqueror's boredom Superman's returned
late in the film comes as a relief to
Zod as debasing the son of joral gives
him something to do starring Terence
Stamp Christopher Reeve Margot Kidder
and directed by Richard Lester critics
say the humor occasionally stumbles into
slapstick territory and the special
effects are dated but Superman 2 meets
if not exceeds the standard set by its
predecessor
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I can't see what's happening
[Music]
number four black panther
the secret shame of wakanda Eric
killmonger Stevens presents a legitimate
concern to King t'challa and his
subjects even if his methods are
woefully misguided should wakanda reveal
itself to the outside world and help
those who live with the legacy of the
African slave trade the characters heady
subtext is backed by Jordan's gifted
abilities as a performer starring
Michael B Jordan Chadwick Boseman Lupita
Nyong'o and directed by Ryan coogler
critics say black panther elevates
superhero Cinema to thrilling New
Heights while telling one of the mcu's
most absorbing stories and introducing
some of its most fully realized
characters
laughs
remember
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's it
[Applause]
number three X-Men
Eric lencher is one of the most
compelling antagonists in comics and
film for one simple reason he's pretty
much right his methods may be
unquestionably cruel to Conventional
humans but he recognizes that two
Sapient species cannot share the planet
violence subjugation and pain are
inevitable and when his point of view is
given mcallen's voice it becomes
incredibly persuasive the more
optimistic philosophy of the X-Men looks
naive and childish in comparison
starring Ian McKellen Hugh Jackman
Patrick Stewart and directed by Brian
Singer critics say faithful to the
comics and filled with action X-Men
brings a crowded slate of classic Marvel
characters to the screen with a talented
ensemble cast and surprisingly sharp
narrative Focus foreign
[Music]
that's enough Eric
let them go
wanna come out when I can see you
Charles
can't you read my mind
number two The Avengers
the power of persuasion is also a major
weapon in the Arsenal of the god of Lies
Loki is charismatic witty exciting and a
sharp dresser he's that bad boy who
looks redeemable even as he opens a
wormhole to let the chatari invade Earth
but when he has a good explanation for
his bad choices he was raised by The God
Who kidnapped him from his real family
and he means to do good so shouldn't
that be enough it is no wonder Loki
returns to the MCU time and again his
brand of villainy looks like it can be
reasoned with even if he betrays Thor
again again and again starring Tom
Hiddleston Robert Downey Jr Chris Evans
and directed by Joss Whedon critics say
thanks to a script that emphasizes its
Hero's humanity and a wealth of super
powered set pieces The Avengers lives up
to its hype and raises the bar for
Marvel at the movies sir please put down
the spear
oh God
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Batman Returns
while DC Comics is favorite Cab burglar
skirts the line between villain and near
Duo Catwoman's initial involvement in a
plot to disgrace Batman earns her a spot
on the list Pfeiffer's performance
defined the character for a long time
even if she was partly inspired by the
TV Catwoman of the 1960s as she fought
Batman and her own turmoil in the end
her Catwoman chose her own way and never
appeared in a film again not that anyone
has ever been able to forget her
starring Michelle Pfeiffer Michael
Keaton Danny DeVito and directed by Tim
Burton critics say director Tim Burton's
dark brooding atmosphere Michael
Keaton's work as a tormented hero and
the Flawless casting of Danny DeVito as
the Penguin and Christopher Walken as
well Christopher Walken make the sequel
better than the first
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
who is she what is she I don't know
whether to open fire or fall in love
you poor guys always confusing your
pistols with your brother
don't hurt us lady our take-home's less
than 300 you're overpaid hit the road
X2 X-Men United
as both spy and Confidant to Magneto
Mystique relies on her top martial arts
skills and mutant ability to blend into
any environment but she's also the most
visible example of Magneto's Crusade
though she can choose to appear as
anyone she wishes mystique's natural
blue Serpentine appearance inspires fear
in the world starring Rebecca Romaine
Patrick Stewart Hugh Jackman and
directed by Brian Singer critics say
tightly scripted solidly acted and
impressively ambitious X2 X-Men United
is bigger and better than its
predecessor and a benchmark for Comic
sequels in general
[Music]
thank you
no one's ever left this car quite like
you we want an apology
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Unbreakable
though he seems to be a mentor Elijah
price is really the architect of all of
David Dunn's problems though he is the
only person to recognize the presence of
superpowers in the world years of abuse
and neglect to say nothing of his
brittle bones lead him to one conclusion
be the super villain the world needs to
find the hero it requires starring
Samuel L Jackson Bruce Willis Robin
Wright and directed by M Night Shyamalan
critics say with a weaker ending
unbreakable is not as good as the Sixth
Sense however it is a quietly
suspenseful film that intrigues and
engages taking the audience through
unpredictable twists and turns along the
way
but I found you
so many sacrifices
just to find you
to cry
now that we know who you are
I know who I am
[Music]
I'm not a mistake
it all makes sense
in a comic you know how you can tell who
the Arts villain's going to be
he's the exact opposite of the hero and
most times they're friends like you and
me
I should have known way back when you
know why David
because of the kids
and finally number one The Dark Knight
in an age when Origins are required
Ledger's Joker arrived on the scene
without a name place of birth or a
particular ambition as Alfred put it he
just wants to see the world burn and he
even tells Harvey Dent as much late in
the film his complete lack of backstory
and motivation makes him the most
unpredictable dangerous super villain on
this list and the purity of his cruelty
makes him the most fascinating starring
Heath Ledger Christian Bale Maggie
Gyllenhaal and directed by Christopher
Nolan critics say dark complex and
Unforgettable The Dark Knight succeeds
not just as an entertaining comic book
film but as a richly thrilling crime
Saga when you look nervous
is it the scars
you want to know how I got them
come here
welcome me
so I had a wife she was beautiful like
you
who tells me
I worry too much who tells me I ought to
smile more
who gambles and gets in deep the sharks
one day they carve her face
I only have no money for surgeries she
can't take it
I just want to see her smile again
hmm
I just wanted to know that I don't care
about the scars
so
I stick a razor in my mouth and do this
to myself
and you know what
she can't stand the sight of me
she leaves
now I see the funny side
now I'm always smiling
a little fight now
I like that and friends that about does
it for us be sure to stay tuned to the
Rotten Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and for
even more news scores and
recommendations on the latest TV shows
and movies head on over to
rottentomatoes.com until next time I'm
your host Naz Perez and we'll see you
back here for more top tens on the
Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]